[MUSIC PLAYING]
WENDY JUDSON: Thank you, Dr.
Shirazi, for coming in today,
and I'm excited to be moderating
this discussion with you.
DAVE SHIRAZI: I'm so
grateful to be here.
WENDY JUDSON: It is about sleep
hygiene, and that is important.
Today, however, our focus
is on sleep disorders
and interventions that
can be made which are
gentle and minimally invasive.
So my first question
for Dr. Shirazi
is, based on all of
these credentials,
I'm especially interested
in your Traditional Oriental
Medicine degree and also
the Spiritual Psychology
and just to find out how that
informs your practice today.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Oh, thank you.
Great question.
So the dental
component allows me
to treat things in a functional
way with oral appliances.
But of course, we're not
just structural beings.
We're energetic beings.
We're emotional beings.
We're spiritual beings.
So when I apply acupuncture
and the philosophies
of Chinese medicine for people
with just straight insomnia,
it seems to be a great adjunct
when treating their snoring
or sleep apnea problem.
WENDY JUDSON: Very interesting.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
WENDY JUDSON: So I
wanted to just give you
an overview of what Dr. Shirazi
is going to discuss today.
And it includes snoring
and sleep apnea,
especially obstructive
sleep apnea,
which is more
common than I knew.
I've been learning a great
deal just discussing this talk
with Dr. Shirazi.
Also related are migraines and
headaches, bruxism, or teeth
grinding, jaw clenching, and
the resulting craniofacial pain,
or TMJ pain.
So what is sleep?
Do you want to give us
a little lesson here?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
So it's a state of consciousness
that every mammal needs.
It's not just that every mammal
has, but every mammal needs.
We say it's absent
from consciousness,
even though there is
mental activity being done.
It's a way for our
physical bodies
to actually shut
down and rejuvenate.
And in fact, the
only time we ever
get growth hormone is during
one specific stage of sleep
called delta.
And it's a time for mental
and emotional repair
and processing, including
memory, which happens
predominantly in REM sleep.
WENDY JUDSON: And moving
on, why, again, do we sleep?
What does it do for us?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
So those are the main things.
It restores our physical,
mental, and physiological
well-being.
And I was just thinking
about this the other day,
about how evolution deemed
that being vulnerable for eight
or more hours in the
dark every single day
is so necessary that
we would even still
have that while still
being vulnerable to attack.
So that tells me,
evolutionarily speaking,
that sleep must be absolutely
essential, that over the years
we could not think of
a better way of getting
our mental, emotional rest
and our physical rest.
WENDY JUDSON: Yeah, so
this is really a need.
And I just want to plug a
book that I read, or listened
to-- because I only do audio
books-- called "Why We Sleep,"
and it goes into
this a lot more.
Why would we voluntarily
choose to make
ourselves this vulnerable for
such a long period of time?
You'll be fascinated,
and it'll--
DAVE SHIRAZI: It
is a great book.
WENDY JUDSON: --change the
way you think about sleep.
This is a map of sleep
deprivation published in a 2015
study in "Sleep Health."
What was surprising
to me is I expected
to see a lot of the dark
areas in urban centers.
And that's not
what we necessarily
see across this map.
Can you speak a little
bit to what's significant?
DAVE SHIRAZI: I'll do my best,
because it's one metric, sleep
deprivation.
Of course, there can
be a number of reasons
why we're sleep deprived.
But the occupation,
for example, that
is most susceptible
to sleep deprivation
are shift workers, people who
work at night and they get--
and they're sleeping
when it's light outside,
and they're awake when
it's dark outside.
That's not natural,
physiologically speaking.
You'll notice that
that map also overlays
over the rate of your
BMI, your obesity level.
And it seems to
match it pretty well.
In that whole, that
panhandle region
is where we see the most obese.
And we know that obesity
can cause sleep apnea.
But more often times, it takes
whatever snoring and sleep
apnea level you have
and exasperates it,
which will of course deprive
your sleep even more.
WENDY JUDSON: So as we go
through these slides here,
we're going to see that
there's a really big connection
between weight gain and
sleep deprivation or sleep
fragmentation, even.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Absolutely.
There is a
correlation, for sure.
WENDY JUDSON: Here
are some statistics.
1/3 of the US
population suffering
from sleep disorders, 75 million
individuals who are chronic
suffers, and 10%, only 10%,
have been diagnosed and treated.
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
So three different
things to mention.
So 1/3 of the population
suffers from sleep disorders.
That's true.
Could even be a little
bit more by the time
this study has been out.
Insomnia is the number
one, sleep apnea
is number two, and then a myriad
of other neurological issues
associated with sleep.
And of course, the
75 million, that's
for sure more now than before.
What's interesting about
the 10% that's been treated,
that's been diagnosed
with sleep apnea.
Yes, it's true, 90%
haven't been diagnosed yet.
But even in that little 10%
subsect, almost entirely
of that 10%, they've been
offered a CPAP for treatment.
And only about 50% of it
hold, stick with the CPAP.
So it's really more 95% of
the population with snoring
and sleep apnea do anything
about it or even know about it.
WENDY JUDSON:
We're going to talk
about the types of sleep apnea.
There are two major areas.
And then as you discuss
the problems that
are associated with
this, can you also
tell us a little bit
about why our palate is
important in the treatment?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Absolutely.
So the most common kind of
sleep apnea, which is like, 85%,
90% of all breathing disorders
in our sleep, is obstructive.
So that has to do with
the way our air flows.
All mammals are
supposed to breathe
in and out through
their nose exclusively,
even when exercising.
Most people who are runners
will say, oh, that's impossible.
But no, actually that's
what we're supposed to do.
And I'm not saying I do it.
I'm just saying
that's what we're
supposed to do as mammals.
So the size and
width of our palate
directly correlates to
our breathing ability
through our nose.
The roof of the mouth is
the floor of the nose.
So if we have a
nice, wide palate,
our nasal breathing
will be much more patent
and we can both inhale and
exhale much more freely.
As soon as we have
a limited ability
to breathe through our
nose, be it through a cold,
be it through environmental
allergies, or even some food
sensitivities, our mouth
has to dynamically change
in order to breathe, because
we need to breathe to survive.
So as soon as this
starts closing up,
our mouth opens and our mandible
rotates backwards, which
limits our ability to breathe.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: Absolutely.
So basically what
you're saying is
the body is going to
find a way to breathe.
DAVE SHIRAZI: No matter what.
WENDY JUDSON: And
it doesn't really
matter what happens to
the alignment of the head
or other parts of the face.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Absolutely.
As we talk about bruxism,
that'll become most evident.
WENDY JUDSON: And
that's what I realize,
because I definitely
have bruxism, but I said,
how can that--
I mean, my mouth is closed.
How can I also have sleep apnea?
So this nasal breathing
and the nasal airway
is truly important and a
source of sleep apnea, as well.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Absolutely.
It could be causal.
WENDY JUDSON: So we're
going to roll a video here
that just gives you a visual
of a person experiencing
sleep apnea.
Do you want to speak
about the opening eyes?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yes.
I absolutely will.
I'll talk through the
video, if that's OK.
WENDY JUDSON: That's perfect.
DAVE SHIRAZI: So you'll notice,
the first thing, the video
hasn't started yet, but
you'll notice on his hand,
he has a home
sleep study device.
I actually prefer home
sleep study devices,
because it's done,
obviously, in your own bed,
and we get a more realistic
response of what's going on.
If I'm more concerned about
your legs moving or insomnia
or something more associated
with the central component,
I'll want to do it in a lab.
There it is.
WENDY JUDSON: Do I
need to move forward?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So you saw that
his eyes just flicked open
just a moment.
So we're actually not
waking up when our eyes open
during an episode.
We're actually just going
from a deeper stage of sleep
to a lighter stage of sleep.
So we're supposed to breathe
in and out through our nose.
In this video shows
exhaling through the mouth,
but that's wrong.
But when we have
an airway collapse,
the drop and oxygen
causes the brain
to tell the intercostal
muscles to just sort of do
a little mini CPR and breathe.
You need to breathe,
restore the airway.
You see how his eyes
opened up right there?
He didn't wake up.
All right?
So he could do that
400 times in a night
and not remember a single
one, because he's still
technically--
and through EEG, we
can see it happening.
He's still technically asleep.
And then you came up with
that wonderful query, which
was, well, if the mouth is
opening and I'm choking,
how am I clenching
my teeth right?
So in the studies
that we see, we
see it about half the time on
people that clench their teeth.
We actually see the airflow
starting to decrease
and then we see the
masseter activity increase.
And then when the
airway is restored,
the masseter stopped clenching.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: The masseter
is the muscle that
opens and closes the mouth.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Correct.
Correct.
So we can even classify it
as a reflex to breathing.
And we see that about 50% of the
time as a cause of clenching.
Even on the very
same patient that
clenches their teeth because
of their airway, as a response,
we'll see them clenching with no
airway disturbance whatsoever.
And in that other
50%, if you will,
we put it under the category
of stress, mental stress,
emotional stress, or even
physiological stress.
WENDY JUDSON: But that is
still sleep apnea then?
DAVE SHIRAZI: In that second--
WENDY JUDSON: In
the second category?
DAVE SHIRAZI: No.
No, that's what I'm saying.
In the absence of
an airway disorder,
you can still clench
50% of the time.
WENDY JUDSON: But you
can still help with that?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah, we can.
WENDY JUDSON:
--through the devices.
DAVE SHIRAZI:
Through the devices,
we can reduce your ability
to clench 50% to 100%.
That's right.
WENDY JUDSON: So this slide
shows us some clinical signs
of OSA, Obstructive
Sleep Apnea, and then
what are called comorbidities.
I had to look that up.
So can you explain
comorbidity and--
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah,
all the things that we
see overlapping, whether it's
correlational or it's causal.
So the first one you see
up there is menopause.
So we definitely see
differences in what
the patient's hormonal
balance is as it relates
to storing and sleep apnea.
So someone with a high
testosterone content
is going to be more
predicated to having snoring
and sleep apnea.
And that's why when
women go into menopause,
we see a shift in the
balance of their hormones
more into testosterone, and then
we see more apneas, typically.
Hypertension, it's very common.
People that have uncontrolled
hypertension, meaning they
tried one or two
or more medications
and it only puts a dent in their
blood pressure, very commonly,
at least 80% of the time,
it's the apnea that's
causing the hypertension.
Obesity, it goes both ways.
Like I mentioned, being obese
can cause you to have snoring
and sleep apnea, but can
actually take whatever you have
and make it worse.
We see that more commonly.
But also, when you're getting
interrupted sleep, when
you wake up, you're more
tired, and therefore you
want to eat more.
And you're not conscious
that you want to eat more.
You just eat more.
And that contributes to obesity,
because you're eating more
calories throughout the day.
WENDY JUDSON: And that's
a hormonal changes
that occurs, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI: And that's
a hormonal change, yeah,
with the ghrelin.
Exactly.
Morning headaches.
That can go in two
different directions.
If you have the kind of
headaches where you wake up
feeling kind of like
an empty head, that's
usually more from an
oxygen deprivation, I find.
Tension type headaches, which
is the most common headaches
in the world,
that's predominantly
caused by clenching
your teeth and how
it pinches on the nerves
in the back of the skull.
And like I said, the number
one cause of clenching
is some form of upper
airway disturbance.
Type 2 diabetes.
We have direct, not just
correlational, but causal
research that shows that
the inflammation that's
caused from sleep apnea can
lead to type 2 diabetes.
And we'll actually see these
very same patients being
treated with either CPAP
or oral appliance therapy
and their blood sugar is
coming down without medication.
So we know there's a
causal relationship.
We don't say it's
the only cause,
but we definitely see
a causal relationship.
WENDY JUDSON: So I went ahead
and skipped to this slide--
DAVE SHIRAZI: It's a good one.
WENDY JUDSON: --that
shows the correlation,
just since we're
discussing that.
We can hop back after that.
But this shows some
of the hormones
that are released or disturbed.
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
So this slide is very
much a condensation.
There is a whole physiological
cascade that's going on.
But from the oxygen
deprivation, we
have the repetitive hypoxemia.
You go through
moments of low oxygen.
But more important to that is
that sleep fragmentation, what
we call the arousal index.
It's the arousals that actually
cause the inflammation what
we're finding.
So your arousals can come from
your own snoring or sleep apnea
or they can come from your bed
partner's snoring and sleep
apnea.
It can come from a
noisy neighbor's dog,
from construction, from a
dog or a cat in your bed
that's constantly jostling or
they themselves are snoring.
That can cause
the fragmentation.
So what the
fragmentation does is
it causes the sympathetic
nerve activity.
We go into fight or flight.
And that causes the
cytokine release.
Well, cytokine release is
just an inflammatory cascade.
It could be not just cytokines.
Could be interleukins.
It could be C reactive protein.
It could be TNF alpha.
But all of those
inflammatory markers
will cause us to
become hungrier,
will cause our sugar to spike,
will cause, like we said,
hypertension, can
lead to-- we now
are discovering that depression
is more an inflammatory disease
than it is anything else.
WENDY JUDSON: So
really a lot of us
are walking around with a
low level of inflammation
that we're not even aware of.
DAVE SHIRAZI: A high level
of inflammation and not aware
of it.
And then on top of
it, this inflammation
causes our blood
brain barrier to open.
So now all these
inflammatory markers
and whatever you ate that day or
drank that night that you maybe
shouldn't have eaten or drank,
now has the ability to get up
into the spinal fluid.
And then you have the weight
gain, the insulin resistance,
the type 2 diabetes.
But then that also contributes
to more sleep apnea,
because you can
either have the weight
gain from just
gain of fat or you
can have the weight gain because
you're retaining more fluid.
And if you have more fluid
in your upper pharyngeal area
or your tongue, that will also
collapse your airway at night
more so.
WENDY JUDSON: All right.
Well, let's look at
that airway and go back
on some of these slides here.
So this is some of the
points of obstruction.
And then we'll look
at the machinery
that you use to
diagnose patients.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
So we have four points of
occlusion in obstructive sleep
apnea.
We have our nasal breathing.
And predominantly,
in my observation,
nasal breathing has to do
with the internal nasal valves
and the turbinate space,
the adenoidal soft tissue,
soft palate area, the tongue,
and the intrapharyngeal space
or throat.
So any or all of those
can be causal or affected,
and they're all
related to each other.
So like we talked about,
if someone can't breathe
through their nose,
they automatically
mouth breathe, which
shifts the position
of their tongue and their jaw.
That make sense?
If someone has a cold or a flu
and their tonsils and adenoids
are inflamed, there's going
to be a change as well.
WENDY JUDSON: So one
obstruction can lead to another,
essentially.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It's an
instantaneous physiological
change in order to
survive and to breathe.
WENDY JUDSON: And what is this?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So we just have
a CAT scan in our office.
It's what called a
cone beam CAT scan.
So it uses just a
fraction of the radiation
of a traditional CAT scan.
It's pretty clever.
Instead of a
traditional CAT scan
that has 2,000 or 3,000
microsieverts of radiation,
this machine goes around
your head and neck,
puts a tiny burst of radiation
as it goes throughout,
and then it extrapolates
that data into a three
dimensional rendering.
That is about 60
microsieverts of radiation.
And a one way flight to New
York is 100 microsieverts
of radiation.
So we're talking really,
really tiny levels.
And then we have the
ability to then look--
you can go to the next slide--
to have a look at the nose
and the throat and the airway.
Now, about this slide
and about why this just
gives us a picture in time.
So what I'm actually
more so than the airway
in this particular slide that
you put up that I'm looking at,
I'm looking at the
position of the jaw.
Because I'm thinking,
if that's what
they look like when they're
wide awake and sitting up,
I'm thinking, what are
they doing when they're
on their back and sleeping?
Because in this case, they're
wide awake and not sleeping.
So more important
to me is what's
actually happening
in their sleep
and in their own
home environment.
So that's why I like to
do home sleep studies.
I like to recommend
that for my patients
so they can find out
what is going on.
WENDY JUDSON: So that
would be the first step
before you get to the CAT scan?
DAVE SHIRAZI: No, we do this--
WENDY JUDSON: Or
you do this first?
DAVE SHIRAZI: We do
this on the initial
as well, just to kind of see
what we have to work with.
Because some people
are just going
to be a straight surgical case.
OK, we've got to
take these things out
or we got to fix your nose
or whatever the case may be.
And some people, if
they're very, very severe,
unfortunately CPAP, it
becomes their best option.
But the vast majority
of the people
in the public that have
snoring and sleep apnea
fall under the mild
to moderate category.
So they're well within a
dentist's scope of practice
to treat with oral appliances.
WENDY JUDSON: That's good news.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
We just need more education.
WENDY JUDSON: Because not too
many people like the CPAP.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yes.
And actually, we were
talking about this
just before we
came on stage, was
a lot of people won't even do
the sleep study, even at home,
because they're afraid their end
goal is going to be only CPAP.
So they're afraid to even
just get started even
having their sleep evaluated.
And that is not
their only option.
I like to go over
the whole thing.
I like to give the patient
every single option I know of,
and then let them decide
what's good for them.
WENDY JUDSON: Now, we've got
some sides here on the sleep
cycle, a couple of them.
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
WENDY JUDSON: So this first one
shows our REM, non REM cycle.
And then what's
significant in this?
It's the same time frame,
right, as the other slide?
DAVE SHIRAZI: It is.
This one just goes
into a bit of detail.
It's actually an older slide,
because currently we're
not measuring what's
called stage four.
We're kind of mixing stage
three and stage four into one.
But we're actually
discussing going back
into measuring stage four again.
So I'm putting it up.
So the different
stages that we have,
so stage one is alpha wave.
We all go into alpha wave as
soon as we close our eyes.
Stage two is a slightly
deeper stage of sleep.
Stage three, and in
this slide stage four,
is the only time where we get
our delta sleep, which is where
growth hormone comes from.
So in children, 50% of our sleep
is delta, because obviously, we
need to grow.
But after we've reached our
ability to no longer grow,
we now need growth
hormone to repair.
So growth hormone is still
essential for our survival,
but we're just using it to
repair instead of growing.
And of course, REM,
like we discussed,
those are the peaks that
you see on that graph
where we get our
mental, emotional rest,
our ability to retain things
that we learned that day,
to process things
that we think are
significant for our
survival socially.
So the brain is
aware of not just
our physical survival but
our emotional survival.
WENDY JUDSON: So
sleep fragmentation
is going to deprive us of a lot
of intelligence, ultimately.
DAVE SHIRAZI:
Yeah, that is true.
We actually see
that in children.
We actually see a
difference in intelligence
in children that have
compromised sleep due to apnea.
WENDY JUDSON: This
has been a thing
that I don't understand,
because now I'm a parent,
so I have to take
my kid to school.
And I don't understand why
they have to start at 8:00.
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
WENDY JUDSON: And
the book I referred
to says a 9:00 AM
start time for schools
is really a lot wiser
and better for kids.
So something to think about and
maybe push for as a society.
DAVE SHIRAZI: The
data definitely
supports that on schools
that shift their morning
time to 9:00 AM, which allows
children to get more sleep,
because children need
more sleep than we do,
they have better outcomes.
Less sick days, better
performance in class.
WENDY JUDSON: We were
talking last week,
and again this morning,
about the importance
of breastfeeding for the
development of the palate,
right?
And why we've done a disservice
by bottle feeding babies.
DAVE SHIRAZI:
Two-fold disservice.
Because when we look at
skulls before the Industrial
Revolution, most of
them had straight teeth.
Most of them had very,
very wide palates.
They had relatively small
sinuses and big nasal turbinate
space.
And we know that the average
breastfeeding period was
between three to five years.
Now, when you're
breastfeeding, if you
can imagine if the nipple
is inside the child's mouth,
the tongue pinches
the base of the nipple
and then makes this little
rolling action over the palate,
squeezes the nipple, and
gets the milk that way.
And when they stop
breastfeeding,
they still swallow this way.
And while we're growing,
it's the tongue that actually
develops the palate naturally.
Does that make sense?
So when we go to bottle feeding,
we have a two-fold problem.
Because one, the
nipple itself is now
suppressing the tongue down.
And two, you're using
your buccinator muscles,
that's your cheek muscles, to
swallow like this, which then
narrows the palate, which then
raises the arch, which means
you really don't even have space
for your tongue to go up there
anymore because it's so
narrow and high arched.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: Yeah.
So we could reduce a whole
lot of this sleep apnea
just by having children
breastfeed for a longer period.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Absolutely.
For sure.
WENDY JUDSON: Which
you say right here.
Can sometimes be
completely fixed when
you discover it early enough.
DAVE SHIRAZI: So that is--
I'm not sure about the data.
I don't know if we've
had longitudinal studies.
Because you have to realize,
understanding snoring and sleep
apnea has only been
going on for 40 years.
Before that, it was
just Pickwickian,
where we talked about the
jolly old fat man that snored
and could sleep standing up.
But we didn't have
knowledge of it back then.
Who knows?
It may not have even existed
in that kind of numbers.
But the point of that
slide, that sentence,
is the only time
we can technically
cure sleep apnea without
surgery is in children
through what's called
functional orthodontics, where
we develop the palate,
develop the tongue,
develop the mandible forward.
That make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: Yeah.
And so in adults,
what we're doing
is trying to just improve.
DAVE SHIRAZI: We can improve it.
The data is not as
conclusive as it
is for children for adults
doing functional orthodontics.
WENDY JUDSON: And these are
just some of the symptoms
of sleep apnea in kids.
So any of you who have kids
may have noticed some of these,
and it might be something
you want to explore.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
The most common
side effect, if you
will, or symptom of
snoring and sleep apnea
in children, interrupted sleep,
is hyperactivity and ADD.
That's the most
common one of all.
And it's because
pediatric neurology
is opposite of adults.
So when adults get tired
from sleep fragmentation,
children get amped up and wired
and have difficulty processing
things and sitting still.
Defiance has actually been
overlapped with this, as well.
And the number of
studies that have
shown that correcting sleep
apnea or a sleep disorder
breathing in the child with ADD
or ADHD and then it resolves it
is in the thousands.
It's not a secret.
It's not talked
about, unfortunately.
Most pediatricians, if
you ask them about it,
they would be kind
of blase about it.
But it's something that's well
established in the literature.
And every child should
be screened for snoring
and sleep apnea,
without exemption.
WENDY JUDSON: OK.
Now what about in the elderly?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
The elderly, of
course, need snoring--
sleeping as well, sorry.
But they need less sleep than
children or even adults do.
But their sleep has
changed, depending
on how active they are.
So when we see the
elderly population,
but they're still teaching
at the university level,
they're still physically
active, they're
still getting good
amounts of REM and delta.
The ones that aren't,
we see much less sleep.
And in that population,
we're seeing
a lot of other
neurological diseases being
overlapped to it.
Because instead of getting
hyperactivity and ADD,
we're seeing in the elderly
neurodegenerative disorders
like Parkinson's
and Alzheimer's.
WENDY JUDSON: So we could
avoid some of those.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Potentially, yeah.
So Alzheimer's has been called,
in the last 10 years, type 3
diabetes because
of the relationship
between their inflammation
and their sugar levels,
which my father had, by the way.
So we already know
the relationship
between insulin resistance
and diabetes with sleep apnea.
It's not a far cry to
say, OK, here it is,
relationship with Alzheimer's.
WENDY JUDSON: So
taking care of this
now can really help
us in the future.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
WENDY JUDSON: This
is hard to read,
so I'm just going to skip by it.
DAVE SHIRAZI: No worries.
WENDY JUDSON: Moving on
now to the TMJ or TMD.
Can you clarify what
is the appropriate term
to talk about problems with TMJ?
DAVE SHIRAZI: You hear so
many times, I have TMJ.
OK, so TMJ is just the
name of the anatomy.
Temporomandibular.
Everyone has a TMJ.
TMJ disorder is some sort of
dysfunction associated with it,
whether it's a
dislocation, a broken
jaw, like a fractured jaw and
neck, arthritis, effusion,
swelling of the joint.
It could be a disorder
that falls in there.
So that, nomenclature
wise, the word TMJ
just means the anatomy.
WENDY JUDSON: And the TMD is
the actual disorder or problem
with it?
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
And then it's sort
of like cancer, where
you have stage one, stage two,
stage three, metastatic or not.
It's like we subdivide
different TMJ disorders.
WENDY JUDSON: And we
kind of spoke about this,
but the tongue moving
appropriately in the mouth
is definitely connected
to this TMD problem.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah,
so if you can imagine,
if you're swallowing
properly, if your tongue is
coming forward and
swallowing properly,
it's going to bring
the mandible with it.
But if on the other hand, while
you're sleeping, let's say,
your tongue is tethered
to your mandible
while you're sleeping
on your back,
you've effectively
doubled the weight
of your mandible,
which will close off
the airway a bit more.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
That's very, very hard to
decipher through literature.
But we see it.
There are a countless number
of studies where they actually
do what's called myofunctional
therapy, where they train you
how to swallow properly
when your tongue is
too low on your mandible.
And they'll show a 50% reduction
in AHI scores of the snoring
and sleep.
WENDY JUDSON: AHI scores?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So that's our
metric for measuring sleep
apnea.
A stands for Apnea, when your
airway is closed for 10 seconds
or longer.
H stands for Hypopnea,
when your breathing
is so shallow that it
causes your oxygen to dip 3%
or greater.
And the I stands
for Index, which
is the number of times
per hour you do the both.
WENDY JUDSON: So then
correcting this problem,
what really surprised me is
that the posture can change.
So this forward head
posture that I work on a lot
can actually be mitigated
by addressing TMD.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It depends if
you have both that posture
and you have a TMD
at the same time.
So if this is your
ergonomics all day,
I don't know how much TMJ
therapy is going to help you.
But if you have a TM problem, if
you are mouth breathing, which
is one of the main reasons why
we have forward head posture,
and then you add a poor
ergonomic situation where
you're doing this or you're
on your phone like this
all the time, that is
definitely going to compound it.
WENDY JUDSON: So we
have a study here
and showed that a higher
proportion of headache patients
diagnosed with TMJ
pain, they also
reported more frequent
and intense tooth contact,
more masticatory muscle
tension, stress, and pain
in the face, head, and
other parts of the body
than the non-headache controls.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
This is something we also
commonly see in the literature.
Again, we're probably past
2,000 studies as well,
where we see those with both
tension type and migraine type
headaches have much more TMJ and
clenching problems than norms,
than just people in
the normal population.
And then we also
see studies that
show that when you address the
TMJ disorder, they're both--
either their tension type
headaches completely go away
or their migraine type
headaches can potentially
reduce substantially.
So we definitely
see that overlap.
WENDY JUDSON: That was great.
So here you might want to talk
a little bit about this slide
and what is a migraine as
compared to another headache.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah,
very different.
So a tension type headache,
when we're actually clenching,
imagine all these muscles, not
just the clenching muscles,
but of the neck just
all going like this.
We actually see a compression
of the greater occipital
and greater oracular nerves
at the base of the skull,
and it comes across here, and
it can feel like a vise grip.
And sometimes people will
experience, they'll say,
oh, I went to my chiropractor.
They adjusted my neck and
my tension type headache
went away immediately.
And then I slept and then the
next morning it came back.
It didn't hold.
But when it was in fact
the clenching that kind of
led to it.
Migraine type headache.
So a migraine is what we call a
centrally sensitized disorder.
And what that means
is you all understand
what referred pain is, right?
You have a pinch in your neck
and it makes your arm hurt.
That's referred
pain down your arm.
Central sensitization
is where you
have a chronic,
repetitive pain that
causes actual physical
plastic changes to your brain.
Then that causes other
parts of your brain
to create problems, like
in the case of migraines,
making blood vessels
open and close.
WENDY JUDSON: Is that why the
visual disturbances can occur?
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's right.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
Absolutely.
But it could also
be other things.
You can have burning
mouth syndrome.
You could have
trigeminal neuralgia.
These are all essentially
sensitized disorders.
And what determines which
one you could potentially
have is your genetics.
But then it's what is creating
the response of your genetics
to do that.
Because your genes aren't just--
I find the whole
argument of migraines
being genetic only as
absolutely preposterous,
because someone can go
their whole life, 40 years.
They have, obviously, the
genetic markers for migraine.
They never had a
single migraine.
And then something changes.
They change their diet, they
have sleep fragmentation,
they get a jaw problem,
they have a dental problem,
they have a sinus
problem, and then they
start getting migraines.
So we can't look at the
genetics as the cause of that.
We have to look
at it and go, OK,
what was it in their
environment that created that?
And so migraine
is, if that is what
your genetic predisposition
is, then having
chronic inflammation or chronic
pain induced by your jaw,
by a nasal airway issue, by fill
in the blank, anything that's
connected to the
trigeminal nerve,
can then create a migraine.
WENDY JUDSON: Now, why is the
trigeminal nerve significant?
I'm gonna go ahead through.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It's an extremely
special cranial nerve.
It's easily the biggest one.
It's both sensory and motor.
It anastomosis with
other cranial nerves.
And it's just really
essential to our survival.
It's related to our vision,
our nasal breathing,
and our chewing.
WENDY JUDSON: Anastomosis.
Could you--
DAVE SHIRAZI: Oh, I'm sorry.
The word anastomosis means
kind of merging together.
So you can have a
couple [INAUDIBLE]..
Like for example,
along the face,
an anastomosis with
the facial nerve.
So you can have a
constant facial pain
that then causes the
central sensitization
in the trigeminal nerve,
because they're all connected.
WENDY JUDSON: Right, there's
nine nerves that actually
pass through the jaw, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah,
there's several.
That's right.
There's several.
WENDY JUDSON: So this one goes
back to our reptilian brain,
as do most of the
cranial nerves.
But there, there's the
anastomosis, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Well, no
that's not the anastomosis.
The anastomosis is really
predominantly happening
outside where it starts
to kind of merge together.
Over here, you can
kind of see how close
they are to one
another and how they're
so close to the brain stem.
You see the olfactory,
you see the second.
You see they all
just come together.
WENDY JUDSON: Yeah,
it's a big one
compared to everything else.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It's
much, much bigger.
And that should
tell you something.
The brain is all
about real estate.
Anything that's in
the brain is there
because it really,
really needs to be.
So if we have something that
takes up a lot of real estate,
that means the brain puts
a lot of value on it.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: Yeah.
And then I put this
one in from your deck,
because so often
times people are
coming to me with head,
neck, shoulder pain
because they've been
at the computer.
And yet it could all be
related to the jaw, or at least
a good portion of it.
So addressing that could
help a lot of this.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yes, absolutely.
Just stopping the clenching
or stopping your ability
to clench during the day while
you're working and trying
to control the situation
will go a long way
to relieve either
the muscle pain here
as it refers to other parts of
your body as trigger points.
WENDY JUDSON: Now,
there's another picture
of the difference of
a before and after.
What was this patient given?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So
this is a patient
that had both a sleep apnea
issue and a TMJ issue.
So we're looking
at a number things.
So in my-- there
are many reasons
why we can have
forward head posture.
One, the ergonomics,
like you mentioned
is, in today's
climate, a big problem.
But if you're mouth breathing,
in order to mouth breathe,
you just unconsciously
bring your jaw
forward so you can breathe
through your mouth.
Does that make sense?
Because when you're
nasal breathing,
the air has a nice
little passage of flow.
But when you're mouth
breathing, the air
has to make a 90 degree shunt.
And you have to kind of open
it to make it more arced.
Does that make sense?
So we just unconsciously do it.
The brain has many
reflexes built
into it, many
protective mechanisms
so it doesn't have to
constantly be reminded of things
that it doesn't
consider important.
So if you walked into a
room that smelled very, very
bad, after about
five minutes, you
stop realizing that
there is a smell.
Because the frontal lobe
doesn't need that information.
That's not relevant to your
survival, at that point.
However, if you have
a sprained ankle,
your brain needs to
unconsciously know
that if we have to run
away in an emergency,
we'd put all the weight
on the other leg.
So you oftentimes don't
have to think about limping,
because your brain
automatically does it.
Same thing with breathing.
When we have to
breathe, the brain
can't constantly be reminded
that, oh, by the way,
hold your head here because
your nose is blocked.
It just automatically does it.
And then we come to
swallowing, which
is what we do 2,000
to 3,000 times a day.
When we do it, our
teeth come in contact.
And if we have a
jaw problem, that's
when we're putting the
most amount of pressure
into the nerves of the
jaw during the day.
So then what the brain
can do is unconsciously,
reflexively hold the jaw
a little bit different,
a little bit away from where
the pain is coming from.
But then we have
to swallow again.
So by the way, I just
recently learned myself
within the last couple of years,
swallowing is a survival reflex
because it tells the airway
that it's safe to breathe.
The saliva that passes
tells the brain,
ah, we're good to breathe now.
Carry on.
So when we swallow and
our teeth come together
and the jaw goes back there, if
we have a jaw problem, if you
have a TMJ disorder that's hurt
hurting, much like the limping
on the other leg, our jaw goes--
and by exaggeration,
our jaw goes forward.
But then we have to swallow
again, and when we swallow,
our teeth have to contact.
So when we do, we do a
pigeon maneuver like this.
So if you can imagine
a couple thousand times
a day of doing this
pigeon maneuver,
you're going to have--
WENDY JUDSON: You're gonna end
up with forward head posture.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Potentially, yeah.
WENDY JUDSON: And
the muscle memory
that is associated with
that clenching, too, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI:
Well, the clenching
that we do is with our
teeth together in the back.
So the CPAP, I just want you
to know, I am not anti CPAP.
The CPAP works.
It has something like a 98.7
success rate in treating
sleep apnea, period.
The problem with
CPAP is that it has
a huge failure in patient
compliance, like 40% to 60%,
depending on which
study you look at.
I am not a fan, I
should say, I am not
a fan of CPAP in children.
In the growing child,
I'm very much against it,
unless we're talking about a
central problem potentially
or some other kind of either
brain or genetic malformation.
But for the majority
of the people,
if you can tolerate
the CPAP as an adult,
I'm never going to tell
anyone not to do it.
WENDY JUDSON: But let's look
at what the other options are.
DAVE SHIRAZI: The other
options are exist, too.
You have oral
appliances that do--
so whereas a CPAP is what
we call a pneumatic splint,
it literally pushes--
the air pressure is not
designed to help you breathe.
The air pressure is designed
to blow up your airway,
like you blow up a balloon,
to keep your airway patent.
And so your inhale
and your exhale kind
of fights against the pressure.
But at the same time, it doesn't
allow the airway to collapse,
because you're blowing it open.
You're, basically, you're
allowing the air pressure
to blow your tongue forward.
Does that make sense?
So an oral appliance is
actually called a splint,
like a physical splint as
opposed to a pneumatic splint.
Well, we can potentially
bring the tongue forward,
bring the jaw forward,
lift the tongue,
like instruct the tongue to
go on the roof of the mouth,
help with the nasal breathing
by opening up the nasal valve.
WENDY JUDSON: Now, we're
talking about this type
of a splint, not the kind that
they form around your teeth.
DAVE SHIRAZI: No, that's
the kind I'm talking about.
The kind that's custom
made to your teeth.
Now, this kind of device
that you have showing
is what's called an ALF, an
Advanced Lightwire Functional.
This is a kind of what we call
functional orthodontic device
that we can use in children
to expand their palate
and literally cure
sleep apnea in most.
It also acts, by the way, as
a myofunctional appliance,
because that little center
loop that you see on there
actually helps train
the tongue where to be.
If we get a little
hair in our mouth,
we go nuts until we get it out.
The tongue becomes acutely
aware of that tiny little piece
of hair, because we have so
many nerves in our tongue.
The tongue actually seeks
out that loop and it
helps train the tongue
on where to swallow 24/7.
But then we can activate it and
then develop the palate itself.
WENDY JUDSON: So if I were to
use this instead of my splint
that I have, because
I find my splint,
I just want to
clench more on it.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah, OK.
WENDY JUDSON: So could
I stop clenching?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Potentially.
So let's discuss
that for a moment.
There were studies
done, and I think
you may even have
the slide here,
where they took subjects
that had sleep apnea
and clenched their teeth
and didn't use their CPAP.
They used a night guard instead.
And we found that it
made their apnea worse.
And then they also
clenched worse,
because we found that they
were clenching harder in order
to breathe, is the presumption.
So in this, we actually
have seen studies just
with myofunctional therapy where
there is less clenching just
from knowing where
you're tongue is.
With the ALF, we're
also finding that it
changes your autonomic tone.
It allows your
sympathetic nervous system
to shift more to parasympathetic
and allows more calm,
which allows more natural
physiological reactions
to happen and less of a
response to the clenching.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: It does.
I'm wondering, Cleo, do you want
to speak about your experience,
since you do actually
have this device?
CLEO: I do.
Yeah, so I have an
ALF device installed.
One thing that you said
actually was that you're like--
you can put it in children.
I'm an adult child, apparently,
because I have one of these,
too.
And what it's been
doing is it's definitely
physically widening my palate,
which has been amazing.
But even before I was doing
anything, when he first
installs it, you
don't have any--
he doesn't try to
make it do anything.
You just let your body
adapt to it initially.
And it's exactly
what he was saying
about how my tongue
was immediately
attracted to the metal
part on top right there.
And then I started
sleeping with my tongue
on the roof of my mouth,
and all of a sudden I
was sleeping through the night.
I used to think that--
I was waking up three
or four times a night
to go to the bathroom,
and I thought
it was because I need to
cut off my water earlier
and earlier at night,
and it wasn't helping.
And of course, I'm blaming
the cat for some of this,
too, because he's 21.
I mean, he's kind of a pain.
But it turned out
that it wasn't--
I wasn't waking up because
of the bladder problems.
I was waking up and
noticing that I should
go to the bathroom and thinking
that that was the causation,
but it wasn't the cause.
It was actually that I just
was not getting good sleep.
And I was getting nine
and a half hours of sleep
and waking up tired
thinking, well,
I'm just going to spend
more than 1/3 of my life
in bed, because I can't
seem to get enough sleep.
And now that I
have this device, I
wake up after seven, seven and a
half hours and I'm ready to go.
So it's been pretty--
personally, from my
perspective, it's
been very effective at dealing
with my snoring and my bruxism.
That was basically what
we were trying to target.
And I went to see
Dr. Shirazi because I
used to have a
night guard, which
would prevent me from
grinding my teeth at night.
Didn't prevent me from
What it did was it prevented me
from doing damage to my teeth
when I was grinding at night.
It didn't help me sleep.
It just helped me reduce the
amount of damage I was doing.
And now I don't
wear that anymore,
because I don't clench at night
anymore or grind my teeth.
So yeah, it's been fantastic.
WENDY JUDSON: Outside
of the time where
you might be sore
from adjustments,
does the device bother you?
Do you notice it?
CLEO: I don't really
notice it anymore.
When I have the
adjustments, my teeth
will be a little
tender for a few days,
and sometimes chewing certain
things is more difficult.
But it's not a lifelong thing.
I'm probably going to wear
this for 18 to 24 months,
depending on how quickly
my palate and my teeth
allow the movement to happen.
Because you have to let
your body accept the change.
And then after that, it'll
just be a night retainer
to keep things in place.
WENDY JUDSON: So
there will still
be something that at
least reminds your body.
Like you have the
little loop right now.
CLEO: Yeah.
And I will say that
what I was really
fascinated about with this
was that I know that I only
breastfed for about
two weeks as a baby,
because my mom had
developed an infection
and she had to take antibiotics.
So she couldn't
breastfeed me anymore.
I also know that I sucked
my thumb until I was seven.
I remember it because my
sisters made fun of me.
Older sisters, you
know how they are.
And that was because,
and you'll see this
in children, the place where
you're sucking your thumb,
that spot is the place of where
your tongue is supposed to be.
That's the central
location where
you-- it's a calming
center in your brain
is how you had explained
it to me, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah,
actually, what's interesting
is in Chinese
medicine, you know how
we have that yin yang symbol?
We actually say, because
we call the back the yang
and the front the yin.
The moment where the
yang meets the yin
is right there in that
spot in the soft palate.
CLEO: Right.
So it's right there where a
child sucking their thumb,
they're actually looking
to comfort themselves.
And that trained my brain to--
bottle feeding trained my
brain and trained my tongue
to just rest on the
bottom of my mouth.
And that causes snoring, because
I was choking off my airway,
and the teeth grinding because
my body was freaking out
because it's like, oh,
you can't breathe now.
You're going to die.
So that's great.
Does anyone have any questions
or do you have another slide?
WENDY JUDSON: The
one slide, well,
since he didn't bring up tongues
and the whole tongue reading.
This, because of the
traditional oriental medicine,
I noticed that there
were slides where
they show the scalloping
of the tongue, which
means that, essentially, an
inflamed tongue is resting
against the teeth and the teeth
are making impressions on it.
In Chinese medicine,
that has a diagnosis,
but it also is significant
to this whole issue of apnea
and TMJ, or TMD.
DAVE SHIRAZI:
Well, what's really
interesting is when the
whole tongue diagnosis
phenomenon began, it was first
documented 2,500 years ago,
but it can go back 3,000 or
4,000 years, the whole tongue
diagnosis and the
scalloping and et cetera.
But back then, obesity
was not really a problem
and snoring and sleep apnea
wasn't really a major problem.
It was a transient thing.
So what was interesting was
that they didn't know that.
So in today's time, we know
that when someone is clenching
their teeth, they're putting
neuromuscular tone back
in their upper pharyngeal
muscles and their tongue.
And the tongue only has one
place to go, which is forward,
which opens up the airway.
But it also presses
up against the teeth,
and that's where you
get the scallop lines.
Does that make sense?
So we're seeing that
sort of a different thing
but then still being
relevant, in Chinese medicine,
when we see a swollen
tongue because it's
scalloping against the teeth.
Does that make sense?
WENDY JUDSON: And inflammation
is part of that picture
too, right?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yes, because
when we have inflammation,
we can have edema.
We can hold onto a lot of fluid,
and we hold it in our tongue
as well.
And our tongue is
actually very interesting.
So if our tongue swells up,
because of weight gain or edema
or what have you, and we
even have the surgery,
we actually have a
surgery that takes
the middle section of the
tongue out and folds it back in,
in about six months, when
the pain starts going away,
in about six months,
it grows back
to the same size it was before.
Because we use that
tongue so religiously
in speech and in swallow,
and to say nothing
of eating, that [INAUDIBLE].
WENDY JUDSON: What about loss of
sensory neurons doing something
like that?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Pardon?
WENDY JUDSON: The loss
of sensory neurons
when you cut the tongue.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
It can potentially grow
back, because we just
need [INAUDIBLE].
WENDY JUDSON: Even
all of the sensation?
DAVE SHIRAZI: We
need it, because we
have a lot of what's
called proprioception,
which is nerves that tell
us where everything is.
Our lips are sensitive,
not because of kissing,
but because we don't
want to swallow or put
anything in our mouth that's
prickly that could potentially
be a choking hazard.
When we chew our food,
we need to taste the food
to see if it's extremely
bitter and therefore could
be poisonous.
And we need to also
double check to make sure
that it's not too sharp,
so that we can survive.
So the brain puts
a lot of repair,
puts a lot of nerval real
estate, again, if you will,
into the tongue.
And that's why we see more
so than any other part
of the area, when we get a
cut, it heals the fastest.
WENDY JUDSON: So unfortunately,
we have reached time.
And what's exciting to
me is I don't see anyone
leaving the room.
So maybe we need to
have a second talk just
about the tongue.
Who knows?
But I wanted to put up a
slide that shows where you are
and how to get in
touch with you.
The TMJ and Sleep Therapy
Centre is a worldwide franchise
operation.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It is.
It is.
It was founded by my
mentor, Dr. Steve Olmos.
We do have, I think as of
today, 57 centers or 58
throughout the world.
I have two of them here in
Thousand Oaks and Brentwood,
Los Angeles.
But like I said, all over
US, Canada, Bahrain, England,
Dubai, all over
Australia and Canada.
We're here for you.
You can go on that first
website, tmjtherapycentre.com,
to find a center near you.
Or you can come to our
site, TMJ LA or TMJ Conejo.
And we'll see if we can
be of service to you.
WENDY JUDSON: Great.
Thank you so much, Dr. Shirazi.
DAVE SHIRAZI: It's
been my pleasure.
This felt like five minutes.
WENDY JUDSON: I know.
It went fast.
CLEO: We're going
to take a couple
questions from the audience.
But let's give a round of
applause to him in case people
have to go to the next meeting.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Thank
you guys so much.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming here today.
Quick question.
So what are some
active decisions
or conscious decisions
I can make now
that would improve my sleep?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So what
aspect of your sleep?
So I want to give you the most
relevant answer as it relates
to you, because Cleo and Wendy
told me that you guys have
already had a meeting already,
a Google talk, on sleep hygiene.
So I don't want to be redundant.
I just want to be of
service to you as best--
what aspect of your sleep
or what aspect of sleep
would you like to address?
AUDIENCE: I sometimes
I feel like I wake up
with pain in my neck.
DAVE SHIRAZI: OK.
That is associated with
clenching your teeth
and clenching your jaw, like
we were talking about today.
Because we don't just
clench these teeth.
We clench the upper
trapezius muscle.
And then depending on where
we sleep, it'll make it worse.
So for example, when people
have one sided jaw problems,
we see them sleeping
with their hands
right underneath their jaw,
and they're just used to that.
And they clench and
they shift their jaw
as they're clenching,
which hurts the jaw
and hurts the neck and
shoulders, as well.
If you absolutely have
to sleep like this,
tuck it underneath the
pillow and then do it.
But then have your jaw assessed,
have your airway assessed
and see, OK, why am I clenching?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah, my pleasure.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for all the great talk.
How is this wire functional that
opens up the palate interacting
with, let's say, the aesthetic
orthodontic that many of us
have?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yes,
OK, so usually
in a very, very positive way.
So again, we talked about
what people look like prior
to the Industrial Revolution.
They had the nice, wide
Julia Roberts-style
arches, nice, big, wide arches.
And I find that attractive.
In Europe, that's
what most people have.
They have nice,
big, wide arches.
Their parents breastfeed longer.
The orthodontists
in Europe are not
as eager to extract teeth
and bring everything back.
So the ALF appliance is
devised to actually develop
the arch very, very gently.
So it completely transforms.
I have a lot of before and after
cases to show you, if you like.
It completely
transforms the smile.
Because it's getting
that much wider.
AUDIENCE: But
don't you get gaps?
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
Yeah, so it's not uncommon,
after ALF treatment,
to do a little bit of
Invisalign, something like--
or I should say aligners, not to
throw a brand name out there--
that will straighten the teeth
into where we put the palate.
Does that make sense?
So we're using the teeth.
When we're using ALF,
we're using the teeth
to help support the
palate and the mandible
to where we want it.
And as soon as we start to
see teeth tipping or OK,
maybe we went too
far or maybe we've
reached the body's limits.
Then we can talk about, OK,
do you like the way it looks?
Or would you like to do
some kind of orthodontics
to straighten it?
Or it could even be braces.
Just straighten
that last bit of it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Yeah.
Good question.
And then one in the
corner, as well, too.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, does your--
excuse me-- therapy center
take medical insurance?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So it depends.
It depends.
We're actually in
the process right now
of negotiating with five
major PPO insurances
to be in network.
But historically, we've
been out of network
because it's been such a hassle
with the medical insurance.
And unfortunately,
medical insurance
has gotten more
challenging over time
instead of less challenging.
But we're hopeful that with
this becoming in network
with these five, through
our biller, that we'll
be able to cut
through the red tape
and you guys will be
able to get the benefits
you so rightly deserve from
your medical insurance.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE SHIRAZI: My pleasure.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: That's what it's for.
So if I'm snoring at night and
my sleep is being disturbed
either because of that or
because my wife's jostling me,
would it be beneficial for me
to practice breathing through
my nose more?
Is that kind of the idea?
DAVE SHIRAZI: That's
one of the easiest
thing within your control.
Putting the tongue right
behind your two front teeth
where that bump is,
practicing swallowing
and this kind of
rhythmic motion,
and focusing on breathing
through your nose.
Breathe Right strips, if
you have nasal obstruction,
something like a Breathe Right
strip or a nasal dilator,
is very helpful to
help to force you
to breathe through your nose.
Sometimes we recommend
taping the lips shut, again,
to force you to breathe
through your nose.
Most of my patients that I
recommend that I want in a V
so that you can actually
have a little escape window.
But you have a beard, so
you can't really do that.
Those are the things that
are within your control.
AUDIENCE: What
about guaifenesin?
DAVE SHIRAZI: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What about
guaifenesin to help remove any--
DAVE SHIRAZI: Guaifenesin?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the Mucinex.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Oh, Mucinex.
OK, so if that's
an issue, if you're
getting excess mucus
secretions through your nose,
yeah, that's fine.
So for example, things like
nasal steroids, for example,
it will shrink up your nasal
breathing by almost 100%
for four hours.
And then it has a
drastic rebound effect
where your nose swells up
and you can't breathe at all
after it wears off.
And plus, the preliminary
studies showed that it actually
changes your brainwaves,
your EEG signals,
from the steroid that's
in it, we presume.
So I'm not a fan of
nasal corticosteroids.
If someone was an
athlete and they
were allowed to do
nasal corticosteroids
and we want them to
breathe through their nose
and they're having a flu or
something that stops them,
OK, go ahead, do it.
But to me, it's not
a lifelong solution.
I personally make
my own nasal spray
with essential oils, just
over-the-counter essential
oils.
And just anecdotally-- I haven't
done a study, anecdotally--
80% of my patients that were
essentially addicted to FLONASE
or some kind of
nasal corticosteroid
have put it down and
switched to my nasal spray
and only refer to the
FLONASE as an emergency.
And in my personal
opinion, steroids
should only be used
in an emergency.
It depletes our adrenals.
There are side effects.
You're paying for
it later when you
have chronic corticosteroid
use, whether it's
topical cream,
nasal, or otherwise.
It's fine for short term.
A week is fine.
But we should only be using
it on an emergency basis,
in my opinion, if you
have no other choice.
CLEO: And back to what you
said about the guaifenesin,
I would say that if
you're chronically
having to use something like
Mucinex or a decongestant,
there might be
something else going on.
There might be some
allergy going on,
whether it's an environmental
allergy or a food allergy,
that you can investigate to see
why you're not breathing well
at night.
And it might even be the
case that it's actually
happening during the day,
too, and you don't notice it
because you're actually able
to drain your sinuses better
during the day.
But at night when you're
lying down and everything
can get clogged up.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Excellent points.
CLEO: I think that we have
to take Dr. Shirazi to lunch.
Is there one more question?
OK.
One more question.
Wait, there's a fight.
Arm wrestle.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Actually, three.
DAVE SHIRAZI: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: How long
do you recommend
breastfeed to fix baby's
breathing problem for life?
DAVE SHIRAZI: So, I mean,
obviously there hasn't
been any studies on that.
We definitely want-- to me,
the absolute minimum in my mind
is one year.
We breastfed-- my
wife, we, my wife
breastfed our son
for almost two years.
If someone did it for two to
three, I'm OK with it, too.
When teeth come
into the picture,
we're supposed to
use those teeth.
So we're supposed to have all
our teeth by age two or three.
So all our baby
teeth, I should say.
We should be chewing food with
those teeth when they come out.
Because whereas the swallowing
develops our palate this way,
our chewing muscles
develop our jaws
in this direction, the
vertical direction.
So I often see
this in my office.
Someone will come and
see me and they look--
I don't mean this
in a derogatory way
at all-- they look like a
Japanese animation character,
because they have big eyes and
a teeny, teeny, teeny mouth.
I know that at a
very young age, they
ate predominantly soft food.
They did not put their
[INAUDIBLE] activity
to good use.
And when they have a
little teeny mouth,
their jaw is a little bit
smaller, and they come back up
and they have more propensity
for a TMJ problem later on.
So in my mind, it's at least
a year, two years better.
Plus the other aspect
of it is the first year
of an infant's life, they do
not have a mature immune system.
They get 100% of their
immunity from their gut.
So whether you're breastfeeding
and giving it to them
or you're adding probiotics
to their formula--
and hopefully you're using a
goat milk-based formula over
a soy--
that's how they're getting it.
They're sincerely not getting
immunity for any length of time
from anything else other
than from their gut.
CLEO: Thank you so
much for coming,
and we really
appreciate the talk.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]